If you'd like i could fly you and your
friend there easy peasy lemon squeezy okay
I'll ask him he said he can't come let's
go what was that Welcome back everyone this is
gonna be my full rick and morty season 5 episode
3 video a rick convenient mort there were a whole
bunch of easter eggs and references in celebrity
guest cameos so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the episodes i will be doing videos for
all the episodes this season i'm doing that weekly
giveaway for rick and morty merch all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and just leave
your favorite easter egg or reference from the
episode on the video careful for spoilers if you
have not seen the episode yet we'll work our way
through shot by shot talking about easter eggs wtf
moments cameo scenes and i'll just number these
as we go along to stay organized starting with
the title of the episode a rick convenient mort
which is a reference to an inconvenient truth the
environmental film about pollution global warming
made by al gore which is meant to play into the
whole captain planet planetina character storyline
and that was our major celebrity guest cameo
not the only celebrity cameo but the biggest one
planetina was played by allison brie most of
you probably picked up on her voice because
it's pretty identifiable dan harmon was making
all kinds of jokes about it on his instagram
before the episode because she's like the next
big community main cast member to come guest star
on the show the only core members of the group
from community that haven't guest starred on the
show now are danny poody donald glover and nicole
yvette brown chevy chase as well but i think it's
safe to say chevy chase won't ever go anywhere
near rick and morty the opening scene is them
creating new rick and morty t-shirts that they
can sell as merchandise which is used as sort of
a call out from the writers joking trying to get
people to buy more actual real-life rick and morty
merchandise like please help us earn more money by
buying our merchandise in real life which itself
also plays into the overt commercialism of the
1980s and early 1990s saturday morning cartoons
like the episode is a big captain planet
parody yes but they also try to use shows like
that as glorified toy ads to sell merchandise with
a sort of tacked on moral message at the end which
they sort of call out at various points during
this episode too with their pointing to camera
breaking the fourth wall be a planeteer recycle we
do the power is yours so that's kind of the theme
of this whole rick and morty episode not just
parodying captain planet and environmentalism
but also parodying the blatant commercialism of
those cartoons with this opening like love buy and
merch we can totally sell these the store itself
is just meant to be a reference to stores like hot
topic that do a lot of licensed merchandise and
i love how offensive they're trying to be with
the t-shirts like what is the craziest t-shirt
we can think of which sort of plays in with the
level of hedonism that they get to during the
episode both on morty's side of the story line
and with rick and summer's storyline even though
it was much more overt with rick and summer on
their big apocalypse bar crawl it wasn't like slut
dragons level gross during the episode like they
got really gross with some of their humor but
it didn't quite get to the level of season four
if we're talking about gross out comedy it's going
to be real hard to top that sult dragons episode
speaking of which there were a couple references
to that episode during their apocalypse bar crawl
that i'll point out when we get to that part
of the episode i do kind of wonder though if
they're going to be selling these t-shirts as
merch in real life i wouldn't put it past them
but they intro the whole planet tina story line
with the acid rain and it basically turns into an
in-universe captain planet episode with diesel
weasel the villain vs planetina complete with
cheesy dialogue based on environmental themes the
funny thing about her takedowns which become a
common theme of the episode is that she's actually
super violent when you really look at what she's
doing like when she's dealing with other
people or she's going up against someone else
like the miners later in the episode she gets
really hardcore and they don't really address
it till the end of the episode like here she uses
this giant whirlwind to take out diesel weasel but
the whirlwind also causes a ton of collateral
damage which is meant to foreshadow her turn to
the dark side later in the episode like damn then
she breaks the fourth wall pointing at the camera
doing the big gi joe call out service ad thing
and knowing's half the battle they also did that
during captain planet episodes if you didn't
actually watch any of those episodes you could
probably find some of them online somewhere the
funny thing about this whole captain planet joke
that they were doing during the episode two is
that you may have seen the real-life parody with
don cheadle as captain planet that was also meant
to be like an r-rated hardcore parody of captain
planet it was great and as you can see it also
stars another community actor sort of bringing the
references full circle with live-action gilly and
jacobs showing up that's what i thought punk asses
i'm going back up don't summon me again unless
you're ready for that pain peace you also notice
during this week's episode rick drinks almost
constantly like he almost always has a drink
in his hand from start to finish and the drool is
back on his mouth i think we've decided that the
drool on the mouth is only for when he's been
drinking and it's just that especially in the
earlier seasons he was always drinking in every
single episode and there's just been more frequent
episodes in the later seasons like season four
and now season five where he's not drinking so
you don't see the drool there's a nice season
one episode one callback later in the episode
too when you see him open the door to the ship or
like you see the back of the ship and it's just
overflowing with empty cans there were actually
several callbacks to earlier episodes which is
now a pretty common theme of rick and morty like a
lot of long-running series south park the simpsons
rick and morty has started to reference itself
as old jokes old plot twists more and more so if
you've been watching the series for a long time
you probably spot those pretty easily morty of
course falls in love with planet tina on the spot
ditches rick and they go to eat vegan cruelty-free
donuts and the way they animate this is hilarious
morty kind of turns into the damsel in distress
in this superhero situation like imagine lois
lane being carried off swept off her feet by
superman only as morty and i love the attention to
detail here that the animators are giving to this
the way morty's eyes change when she picks him
up they also do that a little bit later in the
episode too when Planetina gives him that giant
bouquet of flowers the giant arrangement that's
designed to look like a giant morty head then
they transitioned to the planetina commercial
that morty's watching on youtube from back when
her team first started and they sort of explained
the whole twist of the episode like they started
back in the early 90s and it turned it into a tv
show even though they were actually having those
adventures in real life but then they turned their
adventures into a tv show and now those clips are
online like they would normally be for any other
old tv show and it just leans further into the
captain planet references kind of joking about
how they selected their children from each major
ethnicity and they called their group Planetina
in the tina teers because it was captain planet
in the planeteers but the funny thing about the
episode too this big twist with her character is
the way they treat it is that those rings actually
have real power in the rick and morty universe or
multiverse and she really does have super powers
and they had all those adventures and at the end
of the episode she just flies off and is going to
continue to exist here and because she's made of
elements she's not going to die of natural causes
so she's gonna fly off and just keep killing
people trying to save the planet i think in a
situation like that rick probably wouldn't care or
try to stop her as long as she didn't bother him
but basically her arc during the episode is
kind of like ultron's arc in the marvel movies
is basically like avengers age of ultron like
the only way to save the planet is by killing
all these people like you're the problem they
start all the jokes about the big age difference
between her and morty and they treat their
relationship kind of like the detoxified morty's
relationship with that older woman during season
three like he'd been living with that older woman
having with her on the regular for a good hot
minute before rick showed up to bring him back it
is actually a rare episode you notice where beth
doesn't really do anything weird in the episode
she just acts like you would expect a normal mom
to act when her 14 year old son tries to move in
with an adult girlfriend and it's actually implied
that they did have sex later in the episode based
on that epic cutaway dream sequence but it's not
the first time that morty had sex everyone always
points to the mermaids from ricklantis mix-up
the citadel of rick's episode from season 3
got some of that mermaid push i'm really hoping it
wasn't a one-off thing and i could see her again
which they actually just referenced again during
season 5 episode 1 canonizing that atlantis is the
same atlantis that mr nimbus rules over they set
up the whole summer storyline with rick going on
that bar crawl because she just got dumped by
her boyfriend taylor they make a marvel phase
4 reference saying that morty is full on dating
a phase 4 superhero i've talked about the weird
crossover energy right now between rick and morty
in the marvel universe right now there are several
former rick and morty writers who are working on
major marvel series and movies most notably at
the moment michael waldron who's the showrunner
on the loki series he also just wrote the doctor
strange 2 movie and the loki series itself is
kind of a rick and morty style multiverse show
inside the mcu with a whole bunch of different
versions of the character running around the only
thing about this whole rick and summer storyline
it is not super clear at the beginning what rick's
initial motivation is for wanting to get away and
party so badly usually when that happens it's some
fresh heartbreak that he references but he doesn't
reference any specific person that he's trying
to get over during the episode but the whole
idea here is that he actually makes almost the
same mistake that morty does during the episode
like he falls in love on the spot because he's
so desperate to be with someone in fact summer is
probably the character in the episode that changes
the least from start to finish the funny side
detail here too is when morty asks them if it's
weird that planet tina hasn't texted him just
like moments after he just saw her and jerry
immediately says yes best says no just reminding
you how desperate for love and attention jerry is
rick makes a deep impact movie reference when
he's talking about the different apocalypse bar
crawl planets they're going to all the planets are
about to be destroyed in big cataclysmic events
he modifies morty's t-shirt to make it a rick
and summer t-shirt i also love how he low-key
adds that she's definitely gonna get herpes they
take some weird shots at russia for some reason
because apparently parents are more strict in
russia i guess i guess that's the joke there were
also a lot of random shots taken at different
countries later in the episode and because the
arab jokes were so over the top they literally had
the character call it out as morty was killing him
saying i don't represent an entire culture i'm
just an individual character summer references
season 3 with her bigger tit because she messed up
with rick's enlarging device so one of her boobs
is now permanently bigger than the others she also
whips out the pair of 2010 party glasses and the
only references i could think of for this were
that 2010 was the end of the early 2000s decade
in the year 2010 was also the same year as
the epic bp oil spill which is one of the
worst natural disasters in modern history causing
tons of environmental damage which kind of plays
into the whole planetina themes of the episode the
only weird thing about this morty storyline really
is just how sincere they were with it like they
played everything super serious during the episode
and even at the end of the episode there was
nothing to really take it back like none of the
ridiculous twists had anything to do with their
actual relationship like she wasn't lying to him
about anything like she wasn't pretending to be
someone else she wasn't a parasite but even with a
post-credit scene they didn't really take anything
back that that really really gross post-credit
scene we'll talk about that in a second too but
there have been rick and morty episodes like
this where you have a super downer ending like
season two's auto erotic assimilation where he
tries to kill himself at the end they have the big
wildfire scene they set up the running gag in the
episode where she's like this super powerful
hero doing all these saves doing most of the
work and morty flies around with her barely doing
anything just like pointing at people and laughing
in their relationship arc develops so fast that
you're just waiting for some big wtf moment it
did become a little predictable like you knew it
was probably gonna fizzle eventually just because
of how fast it was moving like when morty says
that she's coming to live with them right after
flat out telling beth and jerry that he murdered a
bunch of human beings in cold blood and shows zero
remorse for it so if you take it at face value you
kind of wonder if he's either gone full evil morty
or it's all just in service of a big twist so
at a certain point the episode did become pretty
predictable is also a little bit weird that he's
so ready to take this older woman at the thought
that she has children no worries i am a child
myself i'll love your children then morty finds
out about how terrible all the adult versions of
her team are and they're basically just using her
to make more money as part of this big empire of
entertainment the prop 6 t-shirt that they put her
in seems like it's a reference to california's
prop 6 from back in 2018 that was just a big
transportation spending issue but i think it was
meant to help set up this whole arc with her going
after the politicians that were doing things that
were bad for the environment then rick and summer
set up their whole bar crawl in the grossest
way possible even though the motorboating was
a little over the top you do know that summer's
a freak so it wasn't quite as big a surprise as
some of the stuff that was happening with morty
miss it appears that you have an uneaten allow me
when they land on that first planet rick makes a
hacker's movie reference saying hack the planet
and then they set at the whole daphne arc with
rick sneaking her along with them because she's
just using him to escape the apocalypses and
he's desperate for love despite screaming the
exact opposite earlier in the episode and being
disgusted at morty doing exactly what he's doing
right now basically falling in love on the spot
you also may have detected that daphne was being
played by amy sodaris which is the other celebrity
cameo during the episode i think they were also
making a slight bojack horseman reference with the
horse sex joke as he was crossing the audience to
get to her because amy sedaris also voiced
a character on bojack horseman and all the
rick and morty people are really good friends in
real life with the bojack horseman people and dan
harmon has talked about doing a crossover episode
with bojack horseman then morty has his big hook
up with Planetins who sent him flowers like he's
the girl in the relationship they use the flowers
for the payoff at the end of the episode two to
bookend their relationship with the flower slowly
wilting kind of dying in one falling from the eye
like the face itself is crying the way they play
this dream sequence cut away while they're having
sex is meant to be morty's imagination that we're
watching but because he's a kid like they really
want to play up the idea that he's this little kid
so it looks like a little kid's drawing but
we're watching morty's mental representation
of what he's experiencing right now later we find
out that summer has been using michelle obama's
name on the bar crawl while she's busy doing it
with every alien in sight then as they get ready
to leave you notice that because this party is
so hedonistic they're the dragon skulls in the
background the paper mache dragon floats they kind
of remind me of the slut dragons episode like this
is a sly reference back to that then they have the
joke about her being summoned to the convention
with morty in her arms because she's literally
just being teleported across the planet from
morty's bed and the other funny thing here too
about all their powers as they're combining them
to summon her is that instead of earth is dirt
so it's air fire water in dirt i think just to
make it sound extra lame then rick and summer
go to the next party planet it gets even grosser
like its level of hedonism goes even more over
the top caligula would roll in his grave if he
saw how nasty some of these degenerates got they
also used that to sort of set up the really gross
post-credit scene joke like mom isn't talking to
us now everyone's pissed yep sounds about right
you have to imagine the writer's room when they
were coming up with this part of the episode like
what is the grossest possible thing that everyone
could do at this last planet that we visit
then when morty finds out they're about to sell
planetina to some wealthy arab person they're
trying to stop him from being with her killing
the deal he kills them in this epic montage going
full john wick infiltrating their secret deal
disguised as a pizza boy takes all their rings
then uses those to summon her and go back to the
house you also notice the name of the fake pizza
business that he used for this is called murder
pie which kind of reminds me of game of thrones
season seven episode one with arya baking the fray
pies mmm delicious murder pie i'm not totally sure
which board game this is meant to be a reference
to but the whole dinner scene is just hilarious
in how sincere and over the top they play it like
oh so you just killed a whole bunch of people and
you want to move in as a 14 year old with this way
older girlfriend they try to wrap things up pretty
quickly they go through that funny montage of her
going around with him taking all those people out
you can kind of see his face slowly get more
and more contorted with each new instance
first she burns down that congressman's home then
she kills all the miners and goes full dark side
like she is crazy op and is only now just letting
loose she's been holding back this whole time
morty breaks up with her but like i said the
real wtf moment here is just that they play it
like it's not meant to be a joke and plain attina
implies that she's just going to continue killing
people all over the world to try and save it
going even more full ultron from the marvel
movies and of course there is that wtf post-credit
scene probably the grossest post-credit scene i
think in the history of rick and morty i can't
think of anything that's been crazier than this
if you did spot any big easter eggs in the episode
that i didn't mention in the video just write them
below in the comments i will try to do a trailer
video for episode 4. there's a rumor that we're
going to get a new venom 2 trailer sometime
this week in my full loki episode 5 video we'll
post on wednesday so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss anything
congratulations tr johnson you're the giveaway
winner from my last big rick and morty video
please email me on the about page of my channel so
i can get your contact details everyone click here
for all my rick and morty season 5 episode videos
and click here for my full loki episode 4 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!